people forget about it you know and even
I you know I didn't mention them here
but Stipe is still number two in the
world Stevie's right there I forget
about him also he's not very he's not
active exactly he's not very active he
doesn't doesn't remind people that he
wants to fight he seems like right now
he's all right we're just being on the
sidelines that's all right he deserved
that he's earned that but I mean if
you're not gonna fight I think instead
of me having to slide down the rankings
he should have correct no I agree with
that because you know you want to be
active and obviously steepe from what I
heard the the hold up with the Steve A
Jones thing was a Stipe issue he's like
oh just not ready I know he's put on
size and wanted more time or whatever
but you know stupid is not afraid of
anybody but that could be another you
know pretty big star you could fall on
play